Richard Perry Loving, being a white person,...
...and Mildred Jeter, being a colored person,...
...did unlawfully cohabitate as man and wife.
Richard!
That ain't right!
I believe this is a battle that could go all the way to the Supreme Court.
But we ain't hurting anybody.
The State of Virginia will argue...
...that it is unfair to bring children of mixed race into the world.
Tell that woman to come out here.
I will raise my family here.
I don't care what they do to us.
Get Peggy inside!
I can take care of you.
I know that.
I know we have some enemies.
But we have some friends, too.
You realize this case could alter the Constitution of the United States?
You think you'll lose?
We may lose the small battles but win the big war.
Is there anything you'd like me to say...
...to the Supreme Court Justices of the United States?
Yeah.
You tell the judge I love my wife.